how do you make Nike matter to every
single person how do you make apple BMW
product how do you make it actually
matter the way you make it matter is by
storytelling the way you make it matter
is that story has to hit you we have
different things that are going to make
us interesting people have just not made
the commitment to realizing brand is
actually built in social social by
Nature allows you to create more
creative when you're able to create more
creative you're able to focus on
relevance not just awareness I believe
every Fortune 500 brand does not have an
awareness issue they have a relevance
issue plus we now live in a world where
the algorithms are rewarding content
that is interesting to people
so you know I think the brands need to
make a bigger commitment to Output more
volume more platform strategy more
creative strategy more cultural strategy
we call it pack platforms and culture
and I think the faster they do that the
more likely they'll gain market share
and I think every brand has to go
through that Journey